[Music]
he's just sort of part of the musical
furniture of american culture
it's just wallpaper
with kenny g's music what can you say
how are you feeling
underappreciated in general
i don't think there's anything wrong
with hard work that's a hard lick and i
just played it really well putting in
the reps and then reaping the reward of
i'm really good at this
i think that's why my careers lasted
this long
the fact of the matter is kenny g in the
1990s was one of the most well-known
musicians on this planet somebody asked
me what kind of music do you do was it
jazz i don't know you might think it
might be jazz well is it pop i don't
know you might think it might be pop he
was having a huge impact on defining
what jazz is even though the jazz
community we're looking at his music
with disdain these are songs from my
heart this is the way i just hear it
they think i've decided to play these
kind of songs because i knew they would
sell well
if only i was that smart
people have gotten married to his music
had babies by his music he makes playing
an instrument really cool i've been
listening to him since i was a baby at
the same time he is also one of the most
hated people in jazz
what the hell's not to like
[Music]
there's something deeply powerful about
the fact that that music has reached
millions of people
the fact that what appeals to me also
appeals to other people
that's the beautiful thing
[Applause]
you